House Republican whip Steve Scalise will
play baseball against the Democrats
tonight exactly one year after he was
shot during a practice and almost died
the Louisiana congressman has had nearly
a dozen surgeries doctors weren't even
sure Scalise could walk again now he's
back in uniform and he talked to Nancy
Cordes for his first interview since
getting back on the field she's at
Nationals Park in Washington the site of
tonight's annual Congressional baseball
game Nancy good morning good morning and
I know you guys remember that morning
one year ago today when Steve Scalise
was literally fighting for his life well
this morning he's already out on the
field practicing both teams are his last
surgery was just two months ago but he's
been determined to get back to second
base and participate in an annual
tradition that dates back to 1909 at 52
Steve Scalise is relearning how to play
all right same way he relearned
how to walk what still gives you the
most trouble I'm a limited mobility I
can't move the way I used to it's better
than it was a few weeks ago but uh you
know if the ball is a few feet away from
me it's not as easy to get for his
teammates the fact that Scalise can play
at all is a miracle it is so good to see
him out here the house is number three
Republican has endured more than nine
surgeries to repair internal organs and
install steel plates
after an Illinois man opened fire on the
GOP team at an early-morning practice a
single bullet tore through Scalia's hip
shattered his femur and ripped open
blood vessels then his security detail
brought the gunman down I think the
lowest point was the first time I saw my
kids you know it was it was tough for
them to absorb something like this you
know to know that your dad was shot
somebody tried to try to kill me and you
know to comprehend that for at the time
a 10 and 8 year old and that's that's
really tough
baseball is a big deal for the Louisiana
lawmaker who had been considered his
team's best player so how's he looking
out there be honest looks great actually
he's better than he was before
[Laughter]
Republicans Kevin Brady and john Shimkus
are Scalise is DC housemates what's
their approach at home when it comes to
the PTA are they like tough I don't even
know about the love part it's just tough
his recovery has been celebrated by both
sides the Democratic players set aside a
century-old rivalry last week asked
rally baby how you been welcoming
Scalise to their practice I've still got
that breakaway for for speed the stepped
up police presence was hard to miss has
anything changed over the past year that
would make not just members of Congress
but all Americans safer from gun
violence
you know this this event was unique I
mean you see mental illness be you know
becoming a bigger focus which i think is
a good thing police's pro-gun rights
stance hasn't changed which does not
surprise his good friend and fellow
Louisianan Democrat Cedric Richmond in
his case it was two people that with
guns that was able to say that team to
me this happens far too much in our
country but tonight politics takes a
backseat to pitching and the fulfillment
of a year-long goal for Scalise you
think the Democrats are going to go easy
on you guys knowing that you're still
recovering I'd like to think but I think
that's where the civility and Scalia's
children he says will be cheering him on
from home tonight it's still too
emotional he tells us to watch him out
there in person on the baseball field
which is something that a lot of parents
can probably understand by the way Nora
last year without Scalise on the team
the Republicans lost to the Democrats 11
to 2 so there are some settles to score
tonight that's right Nancy thank you so
much it's so good to see him out there
on the field that you know they set
congressional baseball game they say
it's one of the last bipartisan acts
that's actually happening in Washington
and everybody's glad to see him I don't
know him but you just feel happy that
he's okay one of the best pieces Nora
was the one you did with Steve Scalise
when he was coming back to Congress and
Paul Ryan I'll never forget it Paul Ryan
walking in you remember John and he
literally fell to his knees when he saw
Steve yeah if that was out touching that
was for 60 minutes and I've known Paul
Ryan for 20 years I've been covering
politics I've never seen a politician
cry like that let alone the Speaker of
the House it was all human emotion I
love that moment I'm so glad he's back
I'm a root for Steve this evening for
Steve Scalise that's nice time